[Music]
three generations of one man to be here
tonight on this Academy Award red carpet
what does it mean for you guys in this
great movie
I'm start with this young man right oh
it's just amazing to see how shyrone is
character that's corrupted different in
a way but also the same I think then
when you stepped on the red carpet today
what was that moment like it's surreal
man all of this is surreal for all of us
you were second when heated up like
really really sorry study Oh a major
human I like it
you also had a great moment with Denzel
when you met him on the red carpet tell
everybody about at the SAG Awards
whether that was one of my dopest
experience thus far Madison this is a
Washington he's one of my biggest
inspirations so uh see what happens
tonight got a little excited oh dear
I've been telling you need to do our
role together something I can't really
really talk about what we do have a
project that we're working on yes for
sure so uh stay tuned for that alright
last thing what does it mean for this
movie to be nominated though and how
important is this film it means
everything it means everything for the
industry it means everything for the
world in my opinion
I feel like inclusion acceptance all
these things are the most important
things we have love is the most
important things you have and so for
this film to be receiving what it's
receiving and to be here it's great for
the industry is grateful and said us you
can win that Oscar tonight how good will
a feel I mean it I'm like I know it
sounds so politically recommend but
being here with these guys like seeing
very seeing Tyrell do its thing
Ursula but it would be amazing obviously
come on you know every beyond amazing to
be up there on the stage like that's
that's the pinnacle so to be up there in
front of all these people who are in the
world talking about and receiving a love
for from that we love so dearly that's
life